hey guys it's Greg that's great
nice job we're gonna watch this trailer
guys trick teaser trailer or teaser trip
for death no Death Note
on Netflix yeah now John I haven't seen
any movies but we have seen death now
yeah my we have [ __ ] our way through
a lot of videos might never notice the
only one was very into death there's a
character called el there's a book where
you write in it and people die somehow
and there's this big monster guy who
looks kind of like the Bubba dude like
if the babadook was like an 80s goth kid
at a rave I have to drop off my female
lover
Anita star you could say if you could
tell her so that we let the drop her off
at the airport today and she loved
shooting the show she seen the movie man
he really really really loves death
though and she wasn't in she was going
to be the one who would be here today be
able to make commentary because she's
actually seen the movie said you're here
with us white Americans who don't give a
[ __ ] about Japanese stuff where's my
American booty you know when you want to
have to recast us all why people right
cuz that's the only way I'm gonna watch
this movie I know I need to be exactly
like my life I'm sure you've seen
reactions from people who have seen the
actual death no but there's going to be
a lot of us like John and I who haven't
seen the original Death Note they need
to hook us yeah
they're gonna have to sell me so before
you spend all your effort and energy
posting a comment of why you watch this
if you haven't seen the original this is
why app book yeah man it's a notebook
that has all the names of it because it
kills everyone
Oh
[Applause]
his name is written in the snow shall
die I wrote back
whoa shall we be cool now this is
directed by Adam Wingard I'll just ask
that question okay cool I'm intrigued
I'm curious who also followed up a great
installment of another previous
franchise Blair who it should first off
I think Netflix is the perfect medium to
put this on yeah because you know when
it comes to like adaptations of dark
source material and feeling Netflix is
one of the few companies around right
now that produces high great quality
content without having to worry about
the nekkid reach like a mass audience
without having to worry about well you
know go sell those tickets hello
shrimps and stuff out or we should not
be able to hard to make work yeah let's
make some changes here today more of an
action image with not an academia that
billing Netflix is a great program for
this to come out on and I think the
death notes show is available the
cartoon is available on Netflix oh and I
think the anime sorry might have upset
someone sir I think that's on Netflix -
so great promotional sources as well
there
that's a cool trend to me to me is a
cool trailer it gives you a good hint at
what the movies about if you have we
read the tiny bit about it he gets this
notebook
whatever he writes down there allowed
him to kill anyone and any thoughts
would go out like it like a crusade
against evil upon a detective played by
Sean William Scott that's coming into
the picture oh yeah and him Italians
that right yeah hasn't seen anything
from the original source of juice I
really like the way this is shot the
frames are really cool it seems to be
playing on a lot of that dark high
school ank's experience as well which I
always enjoyed seeing implemented into
this and the big catch of it is how it's
based on an anime the thing though that
I love is that they hired a guy who's
who excels at horror movies and this
looks like it could have some very
strong [ __ ]
element vibes like it was a lot of entry
penis in here the shots where those guys
are walking off the building I just even
would like the ferris wheel falling over
that was a crazy-ass shot they had there
yeah and I'm curious to see what he's
going to do on this level with a
different kind of source material
because I was associated you know Adam
Wingard with being sort of on the DIY
the more indie and rough around the
edges sort of market I'm curious to see
like this seems like a cool opportunity
for him to stretch the muscle though Oh
totally
and I mean like yeah the mood the
atmosphere I thought was cool it seems
like they're going in on the horror like
you said which which makes me happy yeah
I said look like a fun eerie horror film
actually to me yeah and it looks pretty
visual you know it looks pretty I want
to see more images you know I want to
get a sense for how it's they've shot it
yeah cuz with things like these you know
you're coming over from you know manga
and anime and it's stuff that's like
every frame is composed I'm curious to
seeing what his directions like in that
contact and I love these I love cat I
don't know which people in the cast are
like a good pic for who they are
supposed to play I have no idea about
that but will Dafoe is SuperDuper crazy
and I I understand he plays some kind of
creature guy I just seems like a great
choice and I think what keeps Sam feels
watch was a Willem Dafoe is a creature
guy in real life yeah yes Peter
Sarsgaard the most boring actor in the
world I could think of going to foe is
the creepiest man I think in the world
yeah I don't think anything anybody gets
more creepy than willing to so oh there
was that one actor who I don't know his
name I don't know if this is the music
that's actually going to be in the movie
but I like the music a lot to like it
has that horror movie visual imagery but
it doesn't seem like it loose slow at
all it looks like it moves at a very
specific kind of rhythm in which a time
I'd love as yeah Allen just to concede
you know that the human whose name in
written
written in this book she'll die you know
yeah I could think of so many names I
like I always I don't know what to call
this climate her own autism caucus on
this up Rose and Marcos all of the baby
can react he'll write down markula so
let me he died in a funny way you can
follow us on Facebook comes lash the
real rejects that's Greg alpha as the
Greg Alva on Twitter Instagram my name
is John Twitter Instagram at reasons to
Jerry because I haven't changed it yet
from the old name blue house calm me
facebook.com slash three reject us and
tune in next time come get accepted and
rejected and you know where in all this
are you guys they subscribe subscribe
hits the bell to get notified every time
a new video comes out I want you cause
Emoto that [ __ ] so that every time we
got something to tell you you could you
can be right there to hear it you know
you can you can listen close